un tempo il cinema era muto le immagini
scorrevano sugli schermi delle città
impressionando gli spettatori increduli
per quello che i loro occhi
stavano percependo erano spaventati
terrorizzati perché non capivano non
riuscirò a entrare in quello che
vedevano i fratelli lumière alla prima
proiezione in un teatro e primi
novecento riuscivano a far fuggire gli
spettatori semplicemente con le immagini
di un treno che entrava in stazione
del resto come dargli torto fate a
pensare in quel caso la fantasia si è
fusa quella tecnologia e nel contempo
loro hanno avuto la percezione di essere
travolti chiunque sarebbe scappato del
resto ma non bisogna avere timore delle
innovazioni soprattutto se le stesse
aggiungono qualcosa in più a delle
invenzioni di per sé efficienti un
critico letterario canadese disse una
frase molto importante
northrop frye per la precisione la
macchina tecnologicamente più efficiente
che nuovo abbia mai inventato è il libro
oggi abbiamo l'opportunità di potenziare
questa grande macchina e di
implementarla proprio per voi lettori
quello di cui voglio parlarvi è molto
semplice fra l'altro semplice quanto un
secolo fa permise di abbinare la musica
alle immagini del cinema muto di cui
parlavamo poc'anzi
ecco io semplicemente sincronizzato le
immagini non le immagini sulla della
musica in questo caso alle parole e non
all'immagine vorrei stimolare la
fantasia di voi lettori permettendo di
calarvi in quello che è la narrazione in
un modo ancora più efficace
sto parlando semplicemente di una nuova
dimensione del libro si chiama movie
book questo è il movie book
semplicemente l'implementazione del
libro ma non spaventatevi come si
spaventarono gli spettatori dei fratelli
lumière in questo caso sto semplicemente
dicendo che attraverso l'udito
attiviamo il nostro orecchio poetico
durante la lettura per cogliere
l'infinita gamma le sfumature che le
parole da sole spesso non riescono a
dare la sentite la musica
non ci sostituiamo alla fantasia del
lettore bensì la amplifichiamo
esattamente come accaduto adesso quello
che facciamo è semplicemente di
trasformare l'adrenalina la commozione o
la suspense modificando quello che è il
vostro ambiente in cui leggete la vostra
camera il vostro studio la vostra
poltrona preferita rendendola ancora più
avvolgente negli ultimi anni in italia i
lettori sono diminuiti in maniera
esponenziale
solo il 45 per cento dei ragazzi ad
esempio fra il 6 e 10 anni di età
leggono regolarmente non parliamo poi
dei lettori adulti e per carità in quel
caso i dati istat a gennaio 2015
recitano che dal 46 al 41 per cento sono
scesi i lettori dal 2010 oggi
confermando quindi una tendenza che sta
sempre di più diventando inarrestabile
al ribasso addirittura una famiglia su
dieci in italia dichiara di non avere un
libro nella propria casa ma perché le
persone non leggono più dicono che un
anno tempo ma in realtà se guardiamo il
tempo che passiamo attaccato il
cellulare messaggiando mandando comunque
messaggi ghiacciate o via sms oppure
attraverso lo streaming
vediamo il film scarichiamo musica
riusciamo comunque ad avere tempo e
questa cosa che ha fatto pensare e ho
detto cosa posso fare io nulla
in teoria sono uno scrittore non potrei
farne un altro che scrivere e sperare
che qualcuno abbia voglia di leggerlo
quello che vi presento oggi però
attenzione non è il surrogato del libro
cartaceo so già cosa penserebbe a una
nuova idea sarà una fotocopia magari
dell'e book in digitale non è nulla di
tutto questo perché non voglio
sostituirmi a quello che può essere
l'appeal del libro cartaceo lo tocchiamo
lo adoriamo lo sentiamo è bello leggere
un libro cartaceo e non voglio
sostituirlo
né tantomeno a diventare un surrogato
dell'e book però bisogna dire una cosa
che la lettura in digitale
sta crescendo al di là di quelle che
possono essere magari le idee di ognuno
di noi è cresciuta la quantità di gente
che legge in digitale perché economica
perche versatile perché alla fine è
anche comoda da trasportare
ora mi sono chiesto tornando al discorso
di prima per quale motivo non si legge
in italia e soprattutto nel mondo magari
perché stanno diminuendo i lettori non
soltanto qua ma anche oltre confine
perché per tanti leggere è noioso
ebbene sì è noioso non si è più capaci
di far volare la fantasia e io voglio
essere la penna che da quest oggi scrive
un nuovo inizio
apre un nuovo scenario bene questo è il
motivo più la macchina tecnologicamente
più efficiente ritornando alla fase di
prima è un'applicazione che permette di
leggere i libri ascoltandone i suoni
evocati dalle parole sembra un paradosso
perché di solito leggere implica il
silenzio ma non è così
il mio secondo romanzo a napoli sarà il
primo thriller composto con colonna
sonora sarà l'occasione tra l'altro per
capire apprezzare di più quello che
l'abbinamento tra suono e parole lette
attraverso la colonna sonora composta
dal maestro alex fabiani il pianista
avremo modo da giugno quando uscirà sia
nei paesi anglofoni se in italia di
capire che cos'è esattamente il movie
boot
intanto iniziamo a capire cos'è anatomy
bene questo è il booktrailer del libro
riassume un po i contenuti di quella che
è la trama tra l'altro attraverso dei
filmati rilasciati dall academy awards
quindi tutti conosceranno per l'oscar ma
cosa significa il primo libro innovativo
con colonna sonora anatol è un romanzo
che parla di jazz come avrete intuito
magari dall'immagine ma lo fa con un
piglio diverso fondamentalmente perché
permette al lettore di ascoltare i brani
che il protagonista compone all'interno
della trama già di per sé è comunque un
qualcosa di innovativo di particolare ma
il movie book non è assolutamente solo
questo è stato scritto che vedete su
questo palco non è più uno scrittore
bensì si trasforma e diventa in un
regista di libri una nuova professione
perché il move ebook è una nuova forma
intendere la lettura lo farò
tra l'altro con una cosa modo un po
particolare perché questo sistema che
arriva direttamente dagli stati uniti ed
è stato sviluppato in italia nasce da
una mia idea perché ho pensato per quale
motivo non si riusciva a trasformare la
lettura in qualcosa ancora più bello per
carità la fantasia importante tutti
quanti devono permettere attraverso loro
cerca la loro testa di fantasticare
leggendo delle pagine ma possono essere
accompagnato in questo viaggio
ora potete pensare
il libro è collegato al jazz e quindi è
semplice riuscire comunque a fare
qualcosa di questo genere ma in realtà
si pensa te questo sistema è adattabile
a tutto perché si possono udire i passi
di un assassino in un libro thriller o
il rumore del mare in sottofondo mentre
due innamorati camminano su una spiaggia
ma anche il passo sincopato degli zombie
proprio tasto l'avvicinarsi di un
vampiro dietro le spalle di una vittima
ma soprattutto per i più piccoli si
possono sentire il rumore della natura
il ruggito di un leone per un bambino
oppure raccontare le favole di un tempo
come cappuccetto rosso facendo sentire
al proprio figlio l'ululato del lupo
perché questo possa essere la gamma di
quelli che possono essere le tipologie
di lettura attraverso i muri wood
la cosa bella che tutto ciò è
accompagnato dalla tecnologia la stessa
che ogni giorno usiamo ma che quando si
parla di cultura si tende denigrava
quella la tecnologia diventa la nostra
migliore compagna di viaggio
grazie a questa innovativa applicazione
che è scaricabile gratuitamente sul
proprio tablet iphone qualsiasi sistema
di lettura e reader si potrà iniziare a
leggere con un sistema che apre una
nuova era
tra l'altro pensate in metropolitana o
in treno
che bello sarà leggere attraverso un
testo a scorrimento quindi senza
problemi di dover tenere in mano il
libro se non tenere soltanto l'ipad il
tablet ma non dovete sfogliar nulla non
dovete girare la pagina nemmeno con un
dito e ascoltare calarvi nella
narrazione attraverso gli auricolari e
in questo modo berrete totalmente
avvolti dal libro e lo farete tra
l'altro con la possibilità di decidere
la velocità del testo di lettura
ora questo cosa significa che si
amplifica l'esperienza di lettura
aumentando l'appeal narrativo
soprattutto verso quelle nuove
generazioni pensano avvezza la
tecnologia
ecco cosa voglio fare in estrema sintesi
voglio prendere l'immaginazione per mano
e trasformare la lettura è un'esperienza
multisensoriale ora vediamolo insieme
quel figlio di dio era troppo bello
nessuno avrebbe mai pensato che quel
piccolo uomo fosse un bambino di nessuno
la polvere accarezzava l'asfalto fumante
mentre le foglie dei pochi alberi
piantati nelle aiuole ondeggiavano
delicatamente fra i rami aleggiava
nell'aria una sensazione di torpore
troppo caldo per pagare nelle larghe
strade dell'alabama a quell'ora di
agosto nel primo pomeriggio
chi lavorava era lontano da quel
sobborgo della greater birmingham e che
non aveva un lavoro restava a casa
oziare lievitava sulla gente di colore
povertà in degrado
ero leoni che tristi compagni di vita
era come una malattia cronica
se vi nascevi ci accompagnava fino alla
morte difficilmente qualcuno era
riuscito a fare fortuna
partendo dal dall'ara più povera della
contea di jefferson lei sola correva per
quella strada con nessuna picco se
qualcuno l'avesse vista avrebbe avuto un
modo di paura giovane grassa e con il
grembiule bianco sporco di sangue
nessuno tuttavia ebbe cura di notarla
attorno a lei c'era il deserto
la donna si avvicina velocemente
l'apporto dell'istituto come chiamavano
il sam ieri in quel lembo di periferia
era un ricovero per senzatetto e
all'occorrenza un rifugio per bambini
problematici senza padre madre due esili
suore scostano la tenda del refettorio
osservando in lontananza una figura
avvicinarsi di gran passo e superare
cancellino in legno del giardino erano
incuriosite volevano capire chi fosse
poi notarono cosa aveva in braccio e non
si curarono più di lei
sapevano era il testo di un libro già
letto troppe volte in lontananza le
gomme di un'auto
fecero trasferito la donna di colore il
suo sguardo era preoccupato non voleva
essere vista aveva il petto un piccolo
fagotto composto da una lunga coperto di
maglia fatta ma la ragione se con fatica
e gradini di quel fetido l'uomo stordito
dalle esalazioni della cucina ubicata
nel sottoscala un odore acre e salato e
straniante le invase le narici quella
puzza per fatto rabbrividire anche il
più affamato di disperati lì per lì il
pensiero di cosa stessero cucinandolo
cupola mente poi come per caso
tornò a interessarsi del fagotto che
portava con sé lo riposate alla con cura
appoggiando il lato più corto verso
l'ingresso a busso due volte poi
girandosi di scatto iniziò a correre più
forte che poteva senza nemmeno attendere
che qualcuno aprisse la porta
sapeva che di lì a poco qualcuno
l'avrebbe fatto
e non c'è bisogno di aspettare preferì
fuggire prima di essere fermato il suo
corpo incidere non la facilitava e
sovrappeso le sbilanciava le caviglie
rallentando la persona lacrima poi giro
l'angolo e si dissolse nell'aria caldo
dell'alabama come fosse asfalto anche
lei in cura triste città
bene tutto questo è il movie lo potete
trovare solamente in un libro
grazie